When you claims,
for example,
that you throw the baby out with the
bathwater when you're trying to develop
and become a socially acceptable
personality that happens in a different
way as far as he's concerned for each of
the genders and so one of the prices
young would say that we pay and that
this is a very modern idea in some ways
for growing up as a distinctly gendered
society,
is that it's very easy for men to
suppress and fail to develop,
to develop those elements of their
character that might be considered
classically feminine and it's difficult
for women to develop and express those
aspects of their personality that might
be classically considered masculine and
but so young believer that nested inside
the shadow in some sense where the
Contra sexual capacities.
So for example,
for a man given what we knew about the
temperamental difference between men and
women.
It may be that men could be more,
could develop the capacity for true
compassion and care if they,
huh?
They could find that ability within what
they've thrown out in the shadow.
And women,
for example,
could find the capacity to be aggressive
and assertive because that's part of
what they threw out during their stage
of their course of development because
of because of it's a priory
categorization as inappropriate
behavior.
Now,
that doesn't mean that you thought that
there was,
that people should be raised without any
gender identity.
That issue never came up for him.
He just thought that once you had
established a personality that was
sufficiently developed to be acceptable
socially and functional on the
individual level,
then you could have the opportunity to
expand that personality and to take into
yourself elements of of perception and
thought and behavior
that
you wouldn't have had the sophistication
to be able to handle at an earlier stage
of development.
So young would say perhaps that if
you're a male,
you have to become masculine before you
could become feminine,
and if you were a female,
the reverse is true,
but that if your development only star
stops with a narrow and categorical
gender identity,
then there are elements that of of,
of being that you could draw on that
aren't at your disposal and that will
make you weak.
So the shadow breaks up into the anima
anonymous and the atom is female inside
the mail,
so to speak,
in the animist is the male inside the
female and young believe that he could
see those partial spirits manifesting
themselves in people's behavior.
And so he talked about a couple of
typical behaviors that he thought were
associated either with Anima possession,
so that would be in the case of a man or
animas possession in the case of a
woman.
And so he would regard.
If you ever talk to someone who's female
who seems to respond to all of your
propositions with nothing but
argumentation for the sake of
argumentation.
Human would regard that as a
manifestation of possession by the
animus.
And if you ever talked to a man who is a
irrationally possessed by
second rate and few tile emotions,
then he would regard that as possession
by the anima.
So,
and you can see that if you watch for
it.
And if you believe in such things,
the best thing to do when confronted
with someone who's Animus possessed is
just shut up because you're not going to
make any headway.
Because the point of the argument of an
animist inspired argument is to get you
to argue not to win.
Because by getting you to argue the
animus wins.